uh did you hear about norman mcdonald
just this second
i gotta say it again man i i um
i really commend
the uh
the commitment to
those i just wrote a quote by him he
said that he just or not necessarily a
quote but something that was attributed
to him
saying that he just wanted people to
hear his comedy and not respond because
of his situation and how often would
people like
you get sympathy laughs or you get you
know people respond differently just
because they're like oh bless his heart
he's dying
and just the fact he's like i had no
idea it was
yeah it said in the thing he's been
dealing with this for like a decade
decade yeah i had no idea
that's incredible that
i i i totally feel you i was thinking
exactly about that and our
conversation where that initially came
out from talking about chadwick boseman
watching um
black panther at the bowl this past
weekend
and there was a strong sense of
the whole thing feeling very kind of in
memoriam
um
and because it was just you know it's
like
it's hard to square
somebody who's one of their fundamental
one of their fundamental um
should i quickly play you some some
music and get your reaction uh while
it's just the two of us here yeah should
i should i should i
should we invade
play watch listen with a um
impromptu you gotta hear this yeah oh
already ruined damn it
you're about to make out
i spilled almost the entire mug of
coffee on my floor
i was drinking coffee troy now i'm not
drinking coffee
that is basically my number one
paranoia
uh for while we're on camera is that i'm
gonna just like bump my leg
and i've i've done one really bad one
not that long ago where
camera no i wasn't on camera but i i
swiped the coffee mug
and uh just and it was full
and mine extends to like the whole of of
my life of
i'm afraid i'm gonna spill something
because quite often i do routinely but
yeah what i'm saying is it was it was
it's astonishing to look at him
and
i mean obviously i don't think he was
sick during black panther but i believe
he was during the avengers
and when you look and it's like the role
is predicated on being in good shape and
being healthy and projecting
like genuine kind of power and prowess
it's amazing that he
could do that
while that's going on inside and i know
we're kind of revisiting an old thread
but it just was it all kind of washed
back over watching that film
which as a side note was just such a
cool i normally am not a fan of the
the live score concert format uh you
know where you watch the whole movie
with the score being done live by an
orchestra below the screen for the whole
thing to me it's sort of a broken
premise because you basically get the
worst of everything you get you get like
a bad final mix you you you know the you
can't really hear the movie because the
music's too loud or vice versa it's a
concert that's never really about the
musicians like you don't ever actually
pay attention to the musicians you know
there's a lot and and they did things
um
to
enliven it in good ways like there's all
these wonderful senegalese uh soloists
who performed on black panther who were
on stage with the la phil and it would
frequently especially vocals solos like
baba mall it was senegalese
like from senegal
yeah ludwig before the score he went
there for three months and toured and
studied with these musicians and did a
[ __ ] ton of recording of them in senegal
that's in the final recording of the
movie and before going to london for the
orchestra stuff and um
so we had them all on stage as featured
performers in front of the orchestra
like behind the conductor at the foot of
the stage and there were moments where
they would have a solo
it would um
um
the camera would zoom in on them and the
side monitors you know you've got the
you've got the main monitor showing the
movie and the ones on the side are
showing the soloists so they did a good
job at
fighting against the things that i don't
like about that format but
it was still so cool that
[ __ ] almost 50 000 people showed up
to watch this three nights sold out at
the how many people
it's it's three nights in the row
for the you know the bull is eighteen
thousand so it's like
fifty thousand people almost fourteen
six yeah yeah it's just shy
yeah just shy of fifty
forty eight thousand how [ __ ]
eighteen times three jesus baker
my god
um
it's it
the the thing to me is that that's the
way that it used to be right
54.
so it's over 54 or over man
baker
not good no sports
you're right that that uh
that was the way that it was
that's why you had the
obviously you wanted the distance
between you and the screen
but there was an orchestra pit there
and that's why you had this big stage
there as well right like i remember like
the silent arrow you mean
no uh no not even the silent air like
there was a um
there was for the longest time wasn't
that was there not a live
orchestra playing the score for the
movie even before there was even even
when they were the talkies
uh no it's basically the instant they
became the talkies the live musician
thing virtually overnight ended it was
actually why winter you don't know
it's actually it's actually one of those
classic uh sort of technology resistance
stories because um the the american
federation terminations
yes
yeah the um
the musicians union actively uh fought
against it because they basically had
you know like a hundred thousand
musicians in theaters across the united
states who were about to lose their jobs
and did
you know there was like because you know
there's the small theaters the standard
would be like a pianist or an organist
uh improvising along to the movies
yeah there were would they score
something then for that would the
composer be responsible for for making
an arrangement of the score for the that
buster keaton movie or whatever
so the way it worked is there were
standards right
yeah they had like they had these books
that were kind of like
kind of like lead sheet books where it
would say you know chat drama these are
exactly this is suspense music this and
the musician would basically riff
on
you know the requisite scenes and then i
think the movie would
ha would come this part i may be
remembering wrong but if i remember
correctly the movies would basically
have instructions that would come with
them where
the
the you know the the reels of
of footage it wouldn't have been 35
millimeter but whatever the precursor
would have been in those days of
of the like the film canisters
effectively uh showing up to the theater
i think would also come
with
instructions to the musician of you know
like scene one is supposed to be
romantic scene two and and some of the
more ambitious theaters did have
like chamber orchestras but it it's
certainly nothing on the i mean you know
the reason why they had music in the
earliest theaters like it wasn't it
wasn't dramaturgical it wasn't them
looking
at it and going
oh well you know that scene is so much
scarier if we have scary music
it was quite pragmatic it was the
projector was so [ __ ] loud that in
order to make it a more palatable
experience they just tried to bury it
with a musician it was the only thing
they could think because there was no
such thing as a projector booth at in
the earliest days so that the machine is
like
right behind you and they were like you
know quick johnny and he's doing his
hero
[Music]
play me up johnny yeah exactly
um
and so yeah on another show we would
have cut to a family guy clip but we're
not going to talk about that
yeah the the like the stuttering frame
black and white of you know
troy walks up to mike and then cut to
the text where can we go to wet our
whistle
i think we need to make that short film
i i find that
casa linda plaza was the theater that my
dad went to as a kid and he remember
seeing like 2001
but there was a
um it had this beautiful like opulent
almost gothic like
um pillars on the other side behind
where the screen was and and that he
said
yeah because that's where the orchestra
would be
but i mean that would have
very much post-dated the talkies like
that would have unless the thing was
built in what
the 30s
when did 20s were
silent movies and then talkies came
about in 19 wood
it's funny i i was looking to vote i
don't know
i don't know the exact dates
27 27 is the first
sound sync film uh was that the jazz
singer yeah
so that was actually what wasn't that
the actual movie that they used in uh uh
singing in the rain
the jazz the jazz singer is it it's been
so long since i've seen it i honestly
don't it still holds up [ __ ] it's so
good i know that gene kelly was just
apparently a nightmare to work with but
he he was my introduction i used to go
over to my grandparents every
almost every weekend and they would
introduce me to like okay we're now
we're going to watch singing the rain or
we're going to watch uh
south pacific or something
i grew up on those musicals gene kelly
was like i fred astaire i didn't get and
he was just like a little too gangly for
me even though i was gangly but it was
gene kelly that brought like this
athleticism
to it
so good man [ __ ] you was so good all the
all those all those great i mean to me
the the sort of
the sort of reigning champion of it's
it's a different thing we're talking
about but in terms of people that
used like whether it's physical comedy
or
theater type dance it's when you go back
and watch all the old charlie chaplin
that guy was on another level um
he he and it's amazing how
so much of it holds up where you think
yeah it's still genuinely hilarious uh
like just this his subtle mannerisms and
he was a remarkable
um
like his technique as an actor not that
i know anything about
that it just always seemed like there
was a lot of range to what he was doing
even within the narrow confine like even
literally a film with no dialogue
he just
i don't know there's something there's
something magical about well it was
caboose
original way as well there he was
community theater but like watching it
in that in that original way there's a
um it's a british comic called um paul
merton
who i don't know if americans would even
know about to be honest but he's he's a
massive silent movie fan and he runs a
um like a silent movie film festival
every year which which we went to one
time and they have like you know
professional
like i i don't know what what you would
call this like an ad-libbing pianist
basically like someone who who is doing
his own score to the film as it's going
um who's
phenomenally good who always comes in
does that they've re-timed and cleaned
up the footage so everything just looks
beautiful and works and hits the rhythms
that's cool
are they doing anything like like a
different frame rate like are they doing
it at like a 24 or a 30 frame i think
it's just going for consistency because
obviously everything was hand cranked so
it's this it's i think it's similar to
so some of it no some of it is just kind
of an essentially like an uprising of
the film just so you basically are
seeing it the quality it would be what
are the frame rate
well that's a layer on top yeah so
there's there's also i've seen it done
similar to the the the war movie the
peter jackson war movie yeah dude well
exactly they will not be forgotten they
will not be forgotten that's a similar
idea of kind of interpolating the frames
and re-timing as well because that's a
lot of with this lost side of movies
because it was hand cranked it was just
so variable the frame rate you have that
kind of stop starting everything's sped
up everything's slowing down and even
without doing all the clever
interpolation you can still essentially
like standardize the frame rate so it
looks
it's kind of like when you're playing
it's not like when you're playing a
video game with a bad frame rate so it's
a little bit jumpy but the motion looks
better essentially so you can kind of
sometimes that lands better sometimes it
doesn't you could argue that's less it's
like motion blur it's like a cheated
motion blur in a way watch this [ __ ]
who's played death loop
not me i i just stopped playing it like
five seconds ago to come on this yeah
yeah i i i just started
i i have a weird relationship with like
bethesda games um i
i feel like i'm the freshman and they're
the senior
and i'm somehow hanging out with them
and i i want to be as cool as they are
but they're like way more complex and
super complicated and way smarter than
me and i'm just afraid they're going to
find out how dumb i am
and
it's just always the menu systems that
immediately make me go i'm way in over
my head
just instantly they did a great job with
this i had a lovely chat with jason
kelly who plays colt
um
by the way like just immediately in
those first couple of hours you fall in
love with the guy i mean what's the
first phrase that he says he was it's
it's not it's it's some kind of um
some exclamation that he does that's so
funny
it's like what in the [ __ ] how on the
how the [ __ ] are some but it's like the
most
random
form of expletives but man they did a
great job of just seamless integration
of of tone
throughout everything throughout the
mechanics
um
throughout the i love
things that exist for the players
benefit that the
uh character is commenting on the whole
being able to see the world is like is
anybody else saying this am i the only
and then it starts saying it for you
like you're probably is there anyone
else being able to read this or see this
lettering
um i i got my phenomenally well written
immediately like it's just yeah
like instagram world
the tool tips are well written like it's
just it's a really consistency
consistent throughout all of its parts
it's brilliant
awesome have you like looked at it at
all yet
i've got it installed
um i just are you doing are you doing pc
are you doing ps5 or i mean xbox
yeah i
i did it on pc anything that's remotely
a shooter is an instant disqualifier for
for console for me
it was a little challenging installing
on a pc
um
what are you playing on am i installing
it i'm on the ps5 yeah
yeah it was a little steam does that for
you you know you don't have to go into
the command console yourself and you
would think however
troy's like mr robot when he's
installing a game he's got like five
windows open he's doing the whole thing
he gets interested i get into it homie
um no they they wanted to it was like
how you need to uh update your
the drivers for your amd and i was like
i did and it's so there's like this
weird disconnect
between
that's how we're saying hello now
she joined the army
um
um
semper fi we're talking we're talking
about that's marines um we were talking
about
how of course you do that's called duty
have you ever used that loop troy yeah
yeah but it was it was a bit challenging
just to install it um i don't know i'm
saying that word weird for i don't know
what you are install
it's you have to
you have to install it but you have to
do an install
like you wouldn't say one is a noun one
is a verb so that's what it is so it
really helps you install but you're
installing a game yes i i really really
really hope i'm with you
episode 76 of play watch listen is going
to be solely about like tool tips for
steam you know and how to make sure that
your you know directory is being pointed
too accurately and that you're yeah but
it totally is like cdc
but i did this thing it was like your
resolution is too high i didn't touch
anything no resolution can be a pain in
the ass someone with a super ultra wide
monitor there are loads of games that
are just like we disagree with your
resolution yeah it causes a lot of
problems so
to implement as well though you know
i
should just get good
why we literally
two of us now own ultrawide monitors
not fully but partially so we can test
the games on ultrawide because it's just
a good question i'll try yeah
so you know exactly
i had that exact thing happen on the
pathless where um
the gaming rig
here at the studio i set up an ultra
wide monitor for and then they sent me
uh you know they would do like nightly
build of the game on their on their
server and i pulled it down
and once i had that monitor installed it
was just like the whole world went
and warped like crazy
and it had this like forced perspective
thing going on that it was doing to try
to compensate and i was apparently the
only one who had thought to open the
gate and i did it unthinkingly i just
figured oh if it's not compatible it'll
it'll naturally like window or something
and i'll get but not at all and i
remember i took a screenshot
i took a screenshot and sent it to the
team and they were like oh [ __ ] those
exist don't they yeah like we should
really we should really uh
we should really account for that and so
i ended up being kind of the the tester
uh briefly to to see about the
workarounds because it was yeah it's
really it makes you feel like you're
drunk the way things
the they kind of get time-stretched uh
you know and warped on the edge of the
frame i think it does it with halo
master chief collection but in halo it
kind of looks good like in some games it
works otherwise it just is just perfect
aspect ratio like i love playing sea of
thieves on super ultra wide because it's
just this never-ending ocean like it's
absolutely beautiful i didn't tell it
that i have a green screen and it's
confused oh it's so confused
has anyone have you used your uh your
reprisal is that what it would be
the
your two you're basically your two lives
yeah yeah yeah
yeah i just rushed i i leroy jenkins to
myself and just ran right into a uh a
fire fight
and boy you can get your ass kicked but
there's one little thing that says like
this is gonna go wrong quickly it did
you
i love the fact that
how much have you played
super early i'm i'm in uh still on the
train it doesn't take very long until
you can't get your ass kicked
yeah
i think i'm only a little bit ahead of
you and i'm already kind of
[ __ ] there's just one particular
weapon that um one of one of them has um
that
ever since i i killed that visionary and
i had that weapon i'm just like now if i
want to i can kill everyone in a level
without really much hassle at all and i
will just kill absolutely everybody and
then just be like let me read your
computers i just i just oh arcane arcane
like added uh it's okay try everything
button to their try everything game it's
such a good idea like it's for i mean
how many of those like how many of those
games have we all played where we've
played in like super cautious stealthy
mode and all our all they did and it's
such it's one of those ideas that's just
so brilliant in retrospect but i imagine
you'd have to go on such a journey to
get to of just like allowing the player
to play all the mechanics and and just
feel through your systems it's it's just
oh it's the same thing hitman did of
course but it's it's really cool if i
did that but also like one of my
favorite examples of that i think what
you're talking about is is um
uh force unleashed right the first one
where you start off playing as vader and
just to get that taste of like this is
where you're going was awesome
how the [ __ ] hold on a second this is
freaking me out
austin
did a plate shot of his own studio he
did he did
man that's [ __ ] with me right now
hard
mission accomplished then he was just
waiting for him to like show up
outside he's like
he's in his car
my my favorite is even more i recently
discovered
a
a
i can i can um
oh very good
invisibility
i've got my harry potter yeah exactly is
it green
no it's red
oh it's great
fun to everybody
oh mike's got it too you look like you
have a frog wow flashback look at that
look at them old digs i can't do
anything cool
um we know this is just how i am now i
was at the dmv earlier and was just oh
you finally went
yeah it was actually awesome you do look
especially pale i think because the way
it's keyed the red out so you straight
up look dead you kind of do yeah it's
probably blue i i appreciate very much
on this to the filter and not just my i
think it is though because it also
rendered some of your skin see-through
for a bit
yeah that's just me just embrace me as i
am austin confirmed ghost
i
yep yep
did you play
divinity original sin too because you
need spirit to see me a great game i've
never i've never even heard of this game
divinity very good game thank you mike
for making me not feel alone have you
ever ever heard time killers how about
that game
i've out of time killers um but
i came into this call and you were
talking about death loop and i got
really excited that video games were
being spoken about so i'm not going to
let you escape it we weren't talking
about video games we're talking about
steam installation
games
i and by the way i was the one that
brought it
to
on brand there's only two things that i
really want to talk about we can also
talk about the new iphone if we want to
talk about that whatever
you want
no there's a new iphone
iphone user i don't give a [ __ ] the
cinematic mode that they just announced
looks super dope um you can truly shoot
a movie on an iphone that's that that's
exciting for filmmakers like like kids
and and people that don't have the money
that's exciting for people who are not
filmmakers who just want to make films
like any time stuff like that gets more
accessible that's awesome you know you
just have to use depth of field and is
it is it all the cinematic stuff do you
see that patrick yeah that's the focus
of different people in a video with
macro photography that lets you shoot
subjects just two centimeters away um
it's yeah that's literally so it's a
filter to do all the stuff patrick
without i need to share this video with
you guys the last latest patrick
williams on like the way cinematic as a
word has evolved in like what it means
to the average punter now
it looks cool the other thing i want to
talk about
if i may be such an imposition is
anybody watching why the last man
wait it's already out
of tv oh i didn't know it was out yes
i was so worried it would be bad
not like all over the internet right now
so here's the weird thing
there was a i think it was going to be
either emil hirsch or shia labeouf they
were going to do a movie
and then
that fell through and then they
announced that they're going to do a tv
series on fx and then that went away
um
then it just dropped they're like it
comes out next like i i saw the trailer
for friday so it was just kind of poor
marketing and they went i
i don't know um but it is alana are you
aware that you have
yes um i have something in my eye and i
decided to turn my camera off so i don't
make people watch me poke my own eye
that's weird i mean
could be
people are into that i don't try to be
polite man i understand um
the
it just dropped and they dropped like
three episodes from what i can tell
uh they're each an hour long
if you've never read the graphic novels
um
i think you would just walk in and be
like this is cool
if you have
it's
it's like a whole other way of
experiencing a medium
but i was just curious if you guys had
had seen it because in the
continuing conversation of adaptation
and transferring from one medium to
another and and what that experience is
like and everything else i was just
curious
but it looks like i am alone so you are
i'm watching your system cinematic
trailer so basically it's a fake rack
focus
yes that you can choose later
so it's the same thing that we do in
games it's the same way that we shoot
our cameras in games we look at a flat
image
data that is applied to a rig and a
character model in an environment and
then we go uh actually i want to be on a
50 here i want to set my focal length
here
my focus point here and then the fall
off is going to happen here so you can
choose your aperture and everything and
basically everything you do in portrait
mode but now it's being applied to video
it looks super dope
stuff that before was only capable of
adapters like beastgrip made um
great
adapters to where you could use like
cinematic lenses like i could actually
use like a a canon prime lens on my
phone
um and i've shot stuff with it before
but it was a it was just an apparatus
and it was kind of clunky and you had to
do a bunch of different settings it's
now baked in too it's funny
i just got on your phone and now i
regret it
what'd you get
uh it's just a 12 because i needed to
upgrade my my iphone did the thing what
they've been called out doing this and
i'm amazed that it's not illegal uh
where a battery would die in like
two three hours
um and supposedly as your iphone ages
because i think i had an eight uh they
artificially decrease battery life
intentionally
yeah you're floating ahead
the as they um
system updates
can include kind of like a
a killer for your phone so just your
battery life is like as they you need a
new phone yep
it's awful
um but i repeat i came to this and it
seemed like we were going to talk about
death loop and i got very excited and
now you're why the lost man now your
iphones i made a desert background
too really okay i talked about those two
things
conversation go ahead i can i can i can
i can tag a funny game-related anecdote
that i recently came across okay uh
y'all [ __ ] take it man
[Laughter]
star wars uh
never
the um
i was watching
the um
the tim kaine
post-mortem on the original fallout gdc
talk
um
and
it was everything about that story of
how they made the very first fallout in
the 90s was amazing it was it was just
fascinating it was such a perfect
demonstration of how different of an era
that was in so many ways first game of
its kind
what
fallout
it depends on what you have
yeah
uh i mean top-down post-apocalyptic
is what i mean
was
because he talks about that in the talk
and i'm actually i'm actually apparently
well great great anecdote austin
thanks the part that the reason why i
love you
the reason why i loved it was uh
um
there was a funny thing in there where
to the exact point you're making about
the iphones
they were instructed by microsoft
to
uh they were making the transition to
windows 95
um
and so they wanted the game
to basically they they were
intentionally trying to get people off
of windows nt
and so they said
they said
it's part of the certification process
wasteland was 10 years before fall now
yeah i thought that wasn't first yeah
right
that is a that is a that is a mandela
effect i'm experiencing right now that's
you want to feel old well they say it's
inspired by wasteland i love that game
still i played that game when i was a
kid and it would have been probably 10
years old at the time that i played it
and i still absolutely adored it i
thought it was fantastic
so they were moving people off windows
nt yes which i've just looked up
windows
they wanted they basically wanted the
game to not work um and the presumption
was
that it would like it wouldn't anyway
because you know
transitioning to a new operating system
you know they're gonna put all their
eggs in the windows 95 basket but
apparently the team did such a good job
at making it sort of broadly windows
compatible that it ran on everything and
so they said wow they said you know
microsoft told them it should fail
gracefully um and it didn't and so they
wouldn't pass certification so they
added code that basically just asked the
system are you on nt and it just crashed
the game on purpose so that they could
then pass their windows 95 certification
which was the last time in the games
industry that that's been done yeah i've
never heard of that before yeah it's
like a it's yeah i it was just that was
one of those funny anecdotes like of all
the talk of the design and how they
iterated on you know wasn't originally
like you know the explicitly kind of mad
max post-apocalyptic and a lot of like
all the systems and the exploration but
somehow that story really stood out to
me in his
in his uh and it was like i think on
twitter i saw the other day a similar
one where somebody wrote that
they were being told um you know this
this game must
uh have x frames per second
at you know
always
and it would occasionally have like a
single frame missing so they basically
just
essentially hacked the monitoring like
the the the reporting the frame per
second tool
to just make it say that's what it was
so they could be that has been done i
promise in hundreds of games
until digital foundry started watching
over all our shoulders that [ __ ] was
being done all the time to get past
milestones doesn't it feel a little bit
like
sorry audio listeners for
everyone else who's watching doesn't it
feel like this is kind of the future of
austin to where he's going to be this
disembodied like
he looks like he's in the star wars
what's up i basically i basically was
just in such a forecast writing music
that i ascended to a new state of
existence wow
was that you when you were playing the
bongos for aliens fire team elite
yes he's intense man it was intense you
liked that ah that was that's very very
fellow right here did the bongos for him
i'd like to do that
i feel like i want to buy what is it an
infiniti
what what's the car commercials that
he's in oh it's a lincoln you're
thinking the lincoln yeah
how do you know that mike surely that
doesn't air where you are
no i know that because the reason he
does those ads is because he was in a
movie adaptation of the lincoln lawyer
which is a series of books that i
exclusively read on planes um you read
the books
i read i've read all the lincoln lawyer
books because they're just very easy
trashy stuff to read they're airplane
books they're really good they're
playing books i like playing books i
have plain books books that i just show
up in books
i i mean i miss planes
i was supposed to be on a plane last
night at planes right now
um 20 years of 911 this week we're mad
at planes this week
uh but i did want to mention the
documentary the 911
no we're upset with planes so that
cancels the name of the documentary
because i've seen people recommend
i think that's wrong 25th hours
that's a movie daniel
david just by john spike is it the one
called inside the president's war room
yeah i don't know the name of it i just
know that it just came out and this was
recommended to me
i'm not certain the one you're talking
about i brought it up to recommend it to
you and now i'm like which one [ __ ] i
didn't think crushing that endorsement
pierce
anecdotes and endorsements of the shows
oh you guys i wanted to tell you about
this amazing thing that happened it was
the um
is it minute by minute is it i'm fairly
certain it's called my life
transformative oh [ __ ] it was like a
national geographic thing right it was
like i ate something
i feel like the fact that i'm invisible
has also made me inaudible do you guys
hear something every once in a while
hear this weird buzzing
plus
9 11 inside the president's war room
there was a documentary that's on apple
plus not hbo called inside the
president's war room that i heard about
oh thank you troy yes that's the one
thank you thank you i don't actually
mind speaking through troy that's going
to be my approach
be with you always
but i'd never um before
this week before watching that
documentary i'd never read any of the
you know you have uh there are
transcripts from what people were they
were calling their loved ones from the
planes that they thought were gonna be
hijacked
oh man it's pretty difficult to make me
cry but i teared up at probably 90 of
them just being like unless it's a book
if it's a book i will cry over books yes
but it was it was that yeah it's it's um
you know it's an interesting question
i've seen people ask each other is where
were you on 9 11 because
globally everybody remembers i remember
where i was on 9 11. like everybody
remember you were what three six uh i
would have been uh asleep
but i remember what happened the next
day because i i yeah i would have been
super young but i remember
uh nobody going to school which even in
australia
was completely unnecessary but everyone
was just so shocked they didn't know
what was going to happen on a global
scale i was like
i was in dallas i was in my apartment in
west plano and my alarm uh
would go off to the radio and it was uh
i listened to howard stern in the
morning
and so
recently listened to like the full
howard stern episode from that day and
jesus christ
it's like five hours yeah he was on the
air for he never went off the air yeah
but i woke up
during the reaction yeah it was i i woke
up
um to the first tower
and then woke up uh or
was listening as the second plane hit
the second tower
so and then it was tv on
um and the dallas stock market shut down
because they're like we don't know
what's happening and so they obviously
immediately suspended trading they
evacuated every federal building
because they didn't know it's like you
know la new york dallas
philadelphia boston chicago because it
kept going you know that was the part
that because the two towers was the you
know obviously the giant visual icon for
all time after that but
then one hit the pentagon and then
another one goes down in pennsylvania
and it was like i'll never forget that
feeling of going you know what's the
what's the um outer bounds of this like
when will this stop is this are there a
hundred more coming you know i mean it
just it seemed it seemed like one was a
one was shocking and then two seemed
impossible and then it was like a third
a fourth it just it it's really
it's amazing how visceral that that what
and how it's so scorched in even like i
was in denver you know and just yeah
still feeling like
you know not safe
or or not extremely unsure of
of um
uh where this is going what's the
trajectory of this
so i mean it is this current nothing
like that has really happened since
it's like the kennedy assassination i
want to say it's one of those things
that everyone who witnessed or was alive
period whether they whether they witness
or not seems to have that same like
hardwired memory attachment to
for that specific national memory but
there it was an unprecedented event
because the
jfk assassination was a
um
really only affected
one person um
911 there had never been there had been
the uh
uh domestic terrorist attack with with
like the
oklahoma city bombing there had been
other like
there was huge
trade center there was a van that blew
up in the garage inside it just didn't
do anything i didn't know that yeah yeah
for about 10 years before i believe it
was in the middle of the 90s yeah wow
wasn't that also tied to bin laden as
well i don't know that i don't know
either i think the bomb i think i
believe i'm going to let up because
there was
i remember where i was the first time i
saw a plane back in the sky
because there were no flights for i
think it felt like forever but i think
it was for three or four days
wow have you ever watched the time lapse
footage of the air traffic control
of the entire planet yes um where it's
just like
oh they suck
i mean seemingly i i'm not i can't say
with certainty but absolutely the united
states went to a hundred percent
grounded everywhere every plane was
grounded yeah if you watch there's like
time lapse of the little icons of the
planes and where they were like air
traffic controller radar and it's like
over the course of you know i don't know
two hours
every single there's like thousands of
planes in the air and then just gone
empty i was wrong about the van bomb by
the way to be clear just to correct the
record there i i must have seen on a tv
show or something at some point but no
he was not in any way related so was
that a domestic terrorism like oklahoma
um
i feel like i remember being tied to
some foreign government it was tied to
some some i think i think uh yeah it was
it was it was about um israel stuff
middle eastern
arguments i
i don't want to say the wrong things
i'll make sure they're afraid middle
eastern arguments were present people
were open middle eastern arguments
covers it right like i think yeah i
think so a lot of the u.s is something
like i disagreements yeah there's so
much to get into about it because i
remember just the um
the quick span of
it was yellow ribbons around the tree
and it was uh people singing you know
god bless america it was it was a very
quote patriotic time we we came together
as a country it was it was a really
beautiful thing that everything just
stopped everything else um became
bifurcated between two lanes
important and not and the stuff that was
in the not important catalog or column
was
overwhelmingly more significant than the
one that that did matter it was like
family our safety health all those
things that really we
um
distilled it down to the quintessence of
what the human experience is it was a
beautiful time
and then
one thing happened
and that was the institution of a new
branch of the government called the tsa
and everything switched yeah the
department of homeland security
department of homeland security sorry
and it's and it's you know it's forced
the the the tsa which are not police uh
they are not as we saw in that that
situation in miami
they are not even allowed to interfere
in any kind of uh criminal activity or
altercation or anything they have to
wait for the cops to come you could go
through it was interesting reading about
this because for a brief period of my
time brief period of my life i was like
smoking weed like every day
and i would
try to figure out how i'm going to get
it to a place where i was going because
i felt like i couldn't go to sleep
without it
and so finding out what it looked like
to fly with um
like a vape pen or whatever what does
that look like and they're like here's
the deal don't worry about going through
security they can't do anything they can
if they want to they can go hey give us
a second we're gonna go call the cops
because you have this
but it's not like they can bust you it
was it was a very interesting
um i'm not telling people to do that so
they can go transport drugs just it is a
fact it's a public fact that the tsa is
not a police force it is just a
quote security force that is there to
try to um
get ahead of any kind of uh terrorist
attack anyway
um how quickly we we
left behind the whatever we got to do
for our country and i'm glad to live in
america and all that stuff the second
that we had to take our shoes off in a
security line
and it's very similar to the situation
that we're in now with kovid
whereas people go i can't wait to go
back to normal i'm like
it's it's never going to go back to what
it was you can't do that that's it
always moves forward will always be
different and if you don't believe me
go to an airport and try to find
one without a tsa station that's just we
adapt this is what it's gonna look like
now and it'll eventually become normal
it's gonna be okay yeah but a lot those
changes i mean like the patriot act
these are deeply not okay changes um
yeah uh like that that that i i have yet
to hear a single compelling argument for
mass public surveillance by mil by the
um
the intelligence apparatus of the united
states like the
you know i i
i tend to invoke the
um i think it was franklin uh it's
franklin or jefferson quote of you know
those who would trade uh uh liberty for
security deserve neither um you know the
patriot act is sort of the ultimate
manifestation of like yeah you know what
open up all the text messages all the
emails all the phone calls or whatever
because it you know it might prevent
terrorism it's like oh boy
this is uh this is
this is not a uh
it just happened in australia i know
watching what's been going on in
australia has been blowing my mind i i
really it's it's
it's striking um
i think they've given up now it's
because you know this this is such a
good idea of the timeline when i was
there
heaven i went to a football game with 53
000 people
no mosques nobody was worried because
they knew that the entire time you
manage all those invites
i got a lot of friends you know
uh
and now in australia we're all we all
know each other that's the entire
population
together one football game yeah
um
so no masks at all no masks needed uh
because we knew that there were zero
cases in the entire state um i often
would be like do i need to bring my
mosque and my family would be like what
is what why would you do that do you
smoke theaters
everything was completely open and that
it was
the week before
i actually managed to get my flight out
just like delta on one flight flight
attendant brought it in blew up and
everything that they had done
to keep the country
basically like i said like heaven like
covered didn't exist there it was
nothing you didn't think about it
everything was completely normal back to
the way that it used to be
uh just went to [ __ ] because it's so
contagious and then i think what
happened was that sydney tried very very
hard to grapple with containing it and
still is but they can't it's not going
to work it is too contagious that
they're i think it was like a thousand
new cases a day at one point you're like
you're not you just have to accept that
this is done and what they were trying
to hold out for was getting enough
people vaccinated
uh the australian plan was at 80 we open
up 80 vaccinated but they use
astrazeneca which i don't think we even
have in the us
you have to wait three months between
your shots
so half of my family's not even
vaccinated because by the time they got
the vaccine was really really really
late compared to the us and then they
have to wait three months on top of that
so the whole thing's just really really
slow so the minute delta came along
their plans of 80 will open up we'll
just like everything will be cool until
then just [ __ ] blew up and i feel
like they've not known how to handle it
since that hit some of my whole mess
yeah some of my australian friends were
saying also that the vaccine roll out
was largely due to like political
squabbling um at the federal level that
there was basically sort of
between the pharmaceutical companies and
like the prime minister whoever they
were basically just mad at each other
and it sabotaged the whole thing it was
like australia's uh government in
fighting is especially bad i think yeah
we often don't get to elect a prime
minister uh
they just fight with each other and then
replace each other every two years and
we're all like
what is this that's happening mom and
dad are fighting we're in the back of
the station wagon we're trying to get
ice cream yeah
we dropped off all of your rejects you
should have you shouldn't a lot no that
wasn't the joke i was making i was
saying that they inherited our system of
government
the americans do the second week they
are a constitutional monarchy which
to that point though mike if you look at
the first half of the constitution of
our the american constitution
it's very good
but
it's about a shitload of amendments that
had to be made including the fact that
we can't own people so
are you claiming that a document written
predominantly by slave owners might not
quite comprehend how freedom works yeah
there's also like
gun laws
right take 10 seconds to reload
something and like that hasn't been
amended they weren't like well we
weren't talking about ak-47s because
they didn't exist they didn't exist so
that's that's like to to austin's point
is like the patriot act is like we don't
we never get it right the first time but
i do believe that
austin and i were having this
conversation you know the other day
this this the pendulum is swinging wide
right now and the only thing that i have
found for me is that when i try to grab
onto that and stop it from swinging i
just get tossed about
and so instead what i'm trying to do
is make my world small
and watch the pow the pendulum swings
and then make sure that i'm not in its
way
and that doesn't mean anything to
remember though troy is that the
pendulum's being pushed by people like
it's not
swinging by itself
yeah like like there's there's
definitely like like to be clear like
and i think austin's brought this up on
the show before and he's right like
every metric the world is getting better
right on
on a global scale in the fullness of
time
that said the reason it's getting better
is because
you know hundreds of thousands if not
millions of people are actively working
to improve or to change that and
millions of other people are actively
working to kind of push things backwards
in various interesting rights but i
think so
there's a risk there's a risk in what
you're saying so that
if you just stay out of the way of the
pendulum then you're letting the people
who would push it in a bad way
right well this was the rest of the
debate we were having because it was it
was it was it came down to almost a
semantic distinction between
apathy toward
what's going on versus acceptance of i
will i will not single-handedly
re-steer the world and so i i won't
devote energy to righteous indignation
over it it's it's a lot easier to accept
things the way they are as a kind of
as a kind of
was it lord give me the power to accept
the things that are to change the things
i can't except the things that i can't
right the yeah and you know and there's
another part to that as well and the
wisdom to know the difference and that's
the big one so
i feel like that was kind of the point
you were essentially yeah
it wasn't it wasn't detachment from like
caring about the difference between
right and wrong
it is the understanding oh no no i
wasn't accused
it's it's the difference between you
know i i'm not going to waste my time on
a tweet that someone says that i feel is
to me is a great example um i could
someone could lash out on twitter and i
could go all right you know what here is
my chance to activate and do something
and and
be um do my part use my platform and and
respond to this
and that doesn't
move the needle it doesn't swing the
pendulum
i think that enough of that
what my point is is that what what that
will do is that it will
enough people doing that will swing the
piddle in this way and that's not the
point
the point to me is to be able to i am
the point of the human condition the
point of human experience is to be in
relationship with each other that is
that is
vastly proven sociologically we are not
a isolated being we have to be with
other people
so how do i best do that
and if i do something that is
counterproductive to doing that
even if i am
seemingly trying to do the right thing
what's the point it's it's the perfect
joel ellie argument it's like did he
save the world by saving one little girl
and i love that discussion it's like
should he have sacrificed her for the
good of anything but if he was willing
to sacrifice that are we really worth
saving
but for me it's it's i i can't make the
world better by getting angry at it but
what i can do is understand a lot of
people throughout history have gone
really angry and saved the world
lots of people a lot of brilliant things
have been achieved by people who were
pissed off and wouldn't take it anymore
i think you could also prove the
opposite is true as well is that a lot
of damage was done by
being angry right so i i think that more
often what is the type of behavior that
we look to is when cooler heads prevail
when people go all right let's take a
breath and let's try to find it or
instead we can just get angry all the
time but i am but you can you can know
you can channel
like the example always comes up in
apologies i've been i've been the guy
who's not american on this call for a
little while so i've been keeping my
mouth shut on some things but like the
one that i always see come out of
america
is people talking about using martin
luther king as an example the difference
between martin luther king and welcome x
in their approaches to the issue of
civil rights
and what so much of the conversation
like around martin luther king ignores
is all the bits of the speeches that
were angry like you see you always see
that i have a dream speech but they tend
to leave off paragraphs of that speech
that were
righteously angry at the situation of
the world and the unfairness of
the the the white supremacists
essentially that were running the
country
um and he was rebelling against like
there's anger at the heart of every
every uh heroic person who has made the
world a better place there was anger
there there was a frustration no one i
think there's a one word
i don't think that i don't think that
uh
that
troy is saying
that um
it is a
it is a
um
like an action undertaken
due to lack of anger it's the difference
is what is the action being promoted
that's the fundamental difference martin
luther king in all of his anger would
then promote civil disobedience
you know that that's as opposed to
let's go burn down the [ __ ] capitol
building and or this or that or the rest
like that i think he can be anger and
then channel
angry and then channel that anger into
something
that
uh is seemingly
more productive i think also another one
i would just say i think it varies like
it depends on the situation i don't
think that blanket
being
angry or expressing anger even at a
small thing cannot have a positive
influence
i've had too many men on the internet
come to me and write essays of apology
about how i made them reframe the way
that they thought about women they were
attracted to
like genuine like there's this one
that i have saved because this guy sent
me this massive apology that was like
i'm so sorry that i repeatedly was
telling you and everyone else how they
should feel i made such gross
assumptions about you and your validity
in your career that i treated you with a
level of prejudice that i've built my
career around trying to shut down and
then he goes on to say um it was really
[ __ ] cool for you to take the time to
even get angry at me because what you
were doing was giving me a reality fix
so i can
to try to give me advice so i can fix
the way i approach women and it's like
this long long long essay about how i
made this dude
reconsider the fact that he inherently
treated any girl he was attracted to
like an idiot and that he didn't even
know he was doing it and that was just
me getting mad at someone for telling me
i didn't know [ __ ] about video games so
i think that can occasionally be value
in it
just not always i don't i don't discount
that i um
unfortunately i'm gonna have to wrap up
but i would like to respond to that
so
the system that i was given by my
parents especially my dad was um
loudest voice wins and
um
anger is is the most it's the quickest
way to correct it's the quickest way to
educate is the quickest way to control
so as i look at traveler and i want to
make sure that whatever i am giving him
in life is setting him up for success to
be the best man the best human that he
can be
i have to
i said this to austin yesterday i was
like i have everything in my life laid
out as a knolling table right now and
going what is useful to me and what is
not
and the thing that i've realized is that
i
punt to anger as well to be my
first weapon of choice
um
playing death loop right now is like for
some reason because it was the first
weapon that was given to me i always
want to go back to that machete it's
just fast and quick doesn't run out of
ammo i find it for whatever reason it's
the least effective but for whatever
reason it makes me feel better to have
the machete always at the radius so i'm
pressing y yy trying to get back to the
machete
what i'm what i'm realizing though now
is that
the result
is almost agnostic of the method
someone coming to you and saying i have
rethought my position on this
that is always the goal that is that is
the point of discourse
for me where i'm at right now i can get
traveler to stop dead in his tracks by
yelling at him and it will
cause him to stop
what i'm trying to do now is like can i
achieve the same thing
with a soft tone
can i achieve the same thing so i'm not
saying that anger can not
it's impossible for anger to be
effective
absolutely nor that there aren't things
worth being angry about absolutely if he
were to run out in the street i'm gonna
yell
i think as a father your position is a
bulletproof one like my dad had a
terrible temper when i was a kid and now
i can't handle people yelling i will
just
freeze dead nothing i can't even respond
because that was the thing that i was so
used to as a kid that it's made me very
ineffective around people who are angry
for the rest of my life and that's just
because i was around someone who yelled
a lot when i was a kid so as a father
absolutely like i think reasoning that
that's you are setting someone else up
for success for the rest of their life
because that's treating even a child
with respect
but i'm also trying to apply that to all
of my relationships
how can i best deal with because
traveler at the end of the day is just
another human
so if i can deal with him in that way
can i not deal with someone else and go
instead of dealing with you and anger
because i'll never be able to out hate
anybody
but if there's a way that i can i can
always outlove them i can always i
always want to be this is this is my
goal every morning when i wake up
it's it's really easy
i want to be the best part of someone's
day and make sure that i'm not the worst
if i can do that no matter who i meet i
want to make sure that i'm on this call
oh [ __ ]
um with that said i do got to bounce i
but i do want to play more death loop so
we can talk please do i'd really love to
talk about deathly i don't know what i'm
supposed to call this episode [ __ ]
hell doesn't it jamming just loop 911 in
anger
and iphones i don't know what you want
me to do with this one [ __ ] me austin
i did want to say thank you to everybody
who bought the the merch that we
released last week it sold super well in
the first like day so kick ass people
buying caps and stuff it's really cool
well yeah i can see why they put the
cabs the cap is my favorite i think i'm
going to buy one it's very cute i kind
of now want a cap too i forgot about
that yeah i want one thank you
everybody wearing caps mikey are you
okay sad
i'm very tired it's it's like for me
it's because your coffee spilled he
didn't get to drink any coffee spilled
didn't get his coffee all right thank
you for watching everybody i tried to
react to the coffee with love as it fell
over but unfortunately
and it got worse
i think honestly i think if i got angry
i probably would have acted on it
quicker and solved the problem but
ultimately because i
make
tried
to
seemed really nice on paper
it just didn't really work out for me
i'm alone in ps7 video game writer
that's also inventory he's a video game
composer that's mike biddle he's a video
game director and that that [ __ ] is troy
baker he is a video this [ __ ]
don't get angry drink your coffee good
day everyone bye